this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
ten days buddy 10 days
10 days everyone's fresh off a vacation
you guys feel good you're well rested uh
no I'm not no I'm sure not well you
should've been playing for 16 hours now
this way hold on really quick what's a
longer flight Yuda where'd you go Israel
I went from yeah I went down just answer
that Israel chin went to Korea which is
a longer flight Korea I think it's Korea
about 13 hours together okay so that's
adorable I was uh I was 14 and a half
okay so you did be yeah
my lady my lady uh she slept she slept
all the way through did she take
anything [__] no she just went I'm gonna
go to bed and just for 14 hours I got I
I went down for about six hours and it
was a Tossy turn in six hours because I
can't sleep in those you know I was
lucky enough to fly you know first class
but Daddy those beds don't move much and
uh so I didn't I didn't sleep well but
uh
but you know it is what it is dude
because 10 days and uh well too long
isn't it 10 days too long 10 days too
long to be anywhere though and I love my
family but that might be everything is a
little too long in general now now let
me know 10 days if you're working if
you're like when I went to like Europe
and you're touring 10 days that's
different 10 days to chill say touring
chill no hold on what did you say chill
no no I was in a bus Bubba I was doing
tours Bubba I wasn't a bus oh like
touring the city yeah I was I was with a
guy you know where you educate yourself
yeah after one day I'm like no I got it
well I went well one day in Jerusalem I
said this you go and you go to the old
city and you see the old city and those
walls have been standing there for a
long time and then then you see the Dome
of the Rock and you go now why is
everybody trivia questions okay if you
don't know it why is Jerusalem the most
holy city for Jews Muslims and
Christians because that was the that's
where it started right that's where he
what started where what is that it's
okay I don't know because this is not
he's not supposed to do the Old
Testament it's the Old Testament I like
that and you walk through there okay
right who
Jesus no no Jesus Abraham Abraham
Abraham good Baba yep Abraham what did
Abraham do in Jerusalem in that
specification freed the slave no he
didn't that's Moses that's Abe Lincoln
what was this no that's Moses would be
freed the church so did Abe Lincoln he
did Abraham Abraham's confused well
there you go now Abraham did what he
what did God ask Abraham to do might as
well be asking me Engineers should kill
his son kill his son he said sacrifice
Isaac now here's the thing I'm sure this
is a fun yeah vacation sure
well yeah so well so you're bringing
this up too now that's a 5 000 year old
story Abraham God said to Abraham
sacrifice show me how loyal you are to
me sacrifice the son I gave you after
you've tried forever when you were 80
with Sarah your only son now this was
his eldest son and and he goes to kill
his son with a knife and God says hold
it
as soon as you do it boom and We're Off
to the Races now that spot that mythical
spot that's what happened the Jewish
temple then the Ottomans come in the
Ottomans were Muslim the Turks they come
in they take no [__] hey you Jews get
out of here you Christians get the [__]
out of here we got this and we're going
to take that Tempo we're gonna raise it
we're gonna tear it down we're gonna
build a mosque over it we're gonna build
there's a lot of that goes on in the
police
let's tear it down build a mosque let's
tear that down build a church let's tear
that down build a mosque it was about a
lot of that the Jews never did that
because they they were too small they
didn't have enough when you're at that
Temple across the street is there a
McDonald's there there's a merch there's
there is merch everywhere ice cream
there is merch everywhere now Israel is
um a place where you're either uh you're
either fanatically religious
your uh super they're always at War it's
always War Muslims Christian Muslims and
Jews are living together all the time a
lot of rock thrown right oh there's a
lot more here with the rock there's no
there's a lot more than that I wish you
did because there's a lot of stories I
can hit you with I went to the West Bank
and saw the wall where they built a wall
where the Palestinians have to can't
can't go beyond the wall yeah there's a
lot of that stuff so people live in the
south it's all about and it's all about
it's all about people's different
interpretations for sure I know it's
interesting it's history even believe it
right
well listen Brennan you keep saying if
you believe it now if you're a faithful
person I'm sure it's a a beautiful
destination well they see the thing is
Brandon you gotta understand that if you
if you pray if you if you believe in the
Quran or if you believe in the Old
Testament you can believe in the qurans
see Muslims believe in the Old Testament
they believe in the Old Testament
but there's a divide there between Jews
Muslims you see yeah I get it I
understand now Christians they got their
own thing they got their own thing
Muslims and Jews don't believe that
Jesus was God now I went to Jesus's tomb
where they say he was laid to rest right
there in a cave I looked at that cave
that was pretty cool
is he actually later like the actor the
guy who are the two he considers Jesus
Christ I think they know where it was do
we think the reason here's why we don't
know no sure no but here's why they
think they do know
because what so what is it when you're
an invading Army and you come in and you
you enslave it's great to be in the
ancient times because you and I are
hanging out in the business you got you
love your kids do you love your kids and
your wife they kill them rape them oh no
here you go we're gonna come in we're
going to kill you in front of your kids
now your kids are gonna be sold as
slaves your wife is going to be she'll
come over
because that's our lady and your kids
are going to be slaves it's all good
now you religious you got some you
believe in God Jesus cool we're going to
raise that we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna tear that down we're gonna burn to
the ground and we're gonna build on that
site hour hours yeah we're gonna take
over yeah when they're invading in town
I swear I'm with you guys so the Romans
were like you know these these Jews uh
are are these Jews are a little they're
a little crazy here uh so we're gonna
we're gonna build our temples on top
we're gonna we're done with this [__]
we're not going we're gonna kill you all
and we're gonna we're gonna or the
Christians and the Jews became
Christians right the sect of Jews became
these Christians who followed this guy
because Jews were first right Jesus yes
Jesus of Nazareth and then Romans were
like we're done with you guys you're
making too much [__] trouble [__] off
and they built temples on the site where
Jesus did you see Jesus Christ bones I
didn't but so so where Jesus was so the
Christians would go to where Jesus was
crucified where they say he was brought
up to heaven and where he was laid to
rest
so the Christians would gather there and
the Romans were like we don't like this
anymore get the [__] out of there hey
build a site on there and then when when
the Christians took over
Constantine's mother
to went and found out where the Romans
built those temples and that's why they
think they assume he's underneath where
he was crucified
no archaeologist looked into it they did
they did and they saw a body on there
they didn't see a body under there but
they have the slab how about this
there's a slab where Jesus body was
dressed in the Jewish tradition after he
was crucified right the slabs you want
to give him [__] for watching Ghost
Adventures well the slab is still there
Bubba and if you don't think that
everybody who's a Christian comes in
there and touches 100 says yeah I bet
and o'bri put his hands on that thing
hey we could use it right now I felt it
right do one for me I did ah we need it
I felt some power in there right maybe I
should go I felt a little power
you think they can tell when you're full
of [__] Brian do you think that's why it
didn't work out for you bubba come on
it's I did my best yeah now now um food
was nice
food is is depends on where you go
Brandon really depends on where you go
you guys didn't probably didn't have an
end though where'd it go you know the
hot spots Daddy loves Arabic food I grew
up with it yeah so if you're not into
delicious you're gonna be in some
trouble now now I love it I'll eat all
the homos
all this bully all the meat is that but
that's more Mediterranean isn't it yeah
but I wouldn't say hummus but then I
thought oh that's Mediterranean that's
actually Arabic is it oh I like a nice
hobby it's beautiful a thick hummus some
oil a little pizza what I would do is we
went to some of the older we went to
some of the druze the the old the Arabs
who have been there forever and the
women cooked us some homemade [__] knock
your dick into the dirt well why because
they make the cheese and the cows right
there yeah sure because I went a Bedouin
food where they they the chickens and
the Lambs were they killed right there
that's crazy now that's good yep now
daddy lamb chops from everyone right
there you like this though daddy decided
on the ninth day I I'll get Restless
Bubba 9 days nine days bring up Petra I
can't believe you decided to go for this
one Petra just show I want the landscape
so you don't want to do short Petra
Jordan yeah now it's one of the Seven
Wonders of the World
okay
yeah well this looks like some Game of
Thrones oh you have no idea about them
they shot some of the Game of Thrones
there I can't believe you said that so
it's where Indiana Jones was shot uh
they shot a bunch of [__] there no but
can you go that's just what they carved
into it they they this they hadn't found
this place until 18 uh 12 this Swiss
archaeologist but I got I gotta get I
got too long ago no I hate when people
say that it's forever Echo can you get
like just 300 years ago the landscape I
want to show you just 300 years ago I
mean that's all we'd have Plumbing it's
like 300 you know long 300 years ago
it's a long time
um mankind growth now Bubba that's
that's that right there is Petra and it
goes on for Miles okay now I'm there you
think it's a little hot you think it's a
little hot I bet yeah now I also a Grand
Canyon though right it is the Grand
Canyon now go to Arizona right now a
little more a little more ancient and
fast I think that's no that's not more
vast than the Grand Canyon
here's the difference between a Grand
Canyon than that ready for this yeah
there are people that live among those
rocks so you're in the middle of nowhere
Rock people though and you'll see a
[__] tent and some camels
right there you'll see there are people
living there
all right not there that's empty that's
empty that's fast no there's people you
can go there and see where people live
well but they got people have been
living there forever and they live off
of their goats their camels their uh
some bread and some dates in the third
world and that's their world no that's
third world oh that's their world third
world and the third world oh oh when you
see what I when I say right now they're
right now out there in the middle of no
I said to a better one I go I could
throw you out there and you'd figure it
out he goes no problem
and they just live in either caves or in
tents off their camels
bro you didn't need to go 7 000 miles to
see this I'll take you to a trailer park
up the road and these boys are living
crazy well they're real Health the
betterment are a lot healthier true a
lot tighter families now learned a
couple things
and a couple things camels
stink what's smarter than wait what's
smarter a horse or a camel
man I haven't spent a lot of time around
cam can't say a horse this morning
camel's smarter they hold the water
things you like about a camel I didn't
know I love their lips I love that they
spit
well camels get super attached to you
and if you don't think you're going to
get attached to your camel you're sorely
mistaken they get super attached oh you
made a connection with the camel oh I
didn't oh no no they don't you look like
baby camel right you're new hey your
face looks like baby right no no no no
you look like a camel bro that's why he
was all upon you oh no you baby camel
all right there we are he's the same
face as a camel though I look great
don't I I'm in the outback here and uh
that's online
I'm in a caravan right now now they tie
the camels together because you're not
riding the camera on your own that thing
will kick you right off there's baby
camels in the back baby camels following
Career Training
in the process of training my camels
right now
what's up guys at ease just kind of hang
out I'll be back
how hot is it there stay together in a
cluster a tight cluster make sure hey
hot you know the center of the sun yeah
it's the little hotter is it dry there
too no humidity
well there's no water Bob
no no it's it's the most forbidding
terrain and they live off of it how long
we're on those uh sand horses a little
too long
now now here's the thing you look like
you here's the thing uh
you you gotta if you got a male camel do
me a favor
do me a favor
never
mistreat it never
and now I'm talking about if you're 10
years old and you gave it a whip
whipping I'd never forget it'll remember
you it's like an elephant Beyond it'll
remember they're that smart and and the
guy said you would never ever ever you
know how you get it's like late and you
want to take a nap because it's so hot
and you use your camel for shade or you
use your camel when there's a windstorm
don't do the camel like that don't lean
against don't ever sleep against a male
camel why he might decide that he's had
enough of you
and he will [__] kill you he'll just
after 10 years how though this stupid
dull teeth oh I'm so glad you asked
they're so stupid so glad you asked oh
no they take their elbows and they they
jump on you and land Dan Henderson they
Dan Henderson your [__] oh [__] and
they're big they're big right oh they're
about to bring up a male camel weight
they they take you and they they Jam
their elbows until you die they won't
stop until you die and then they go told
you not to [__] with me but I was only
10. 1400 pound animals so you enjoy that
and then they store the water in their
humps right now females will never do
that ever so so so your boy your boy
decides your boy decides hey you know
what I'm done I don't want to do this
tour guide I see a Bedouin and he's got
his horse and they're taking people on
Horseback but they're walking then
they're holding the horse and you know
you know me
this is crazy
they're so stupid looking
angry camel kills young man and Jordan
Right Where I Was don't [__] around B
all right don't worry about stupid camel
oh he'll kill you dude I would love to
see you try to look at this stupid teeth
that ain't stupid take it back they're
my favorite they're my new favorite
animal did you drink camel milk I didn't
you know why suck it dude because they
said no matter who you are no matter who
you are the first time you drink it
second time you will [__] immediately
your stomach yeah but it's super fatty
and Rich they'll they'll milk it right
there and it's warm and you drink it
yeah you just couldn't quite do it
I got on a horse I said to the guy hey I
want to just ride and he goes okay in
the sand you're right I go yeah I get on
a [__] bedouin's horse and arrow Pony
well well my my lady and my family my
dad goes what are you doing what are you
doing I go I'm gonna ride he's gonna say
he's he takes me because I will take you
where nobody is where nobody goes I'm in
I'm like there's barely anybody here
dude I'm in no it's like you know
Petra's yeah Taurus everywhere oh okay
so he I get on the horse and I quickly
realized it's been a long time since
I've ridden a horse and I don't really
know how to turn the horse and the horse
doesn't give a [__] about me and he can
tell he can feel it yeah you can feel it
he if he can if he the forces can feel
for your pushover and then does Ben now
started eating yep you're not allowed to
do that well the horse also he's going
to take me up these Steeps the horse
goes [__] you I'm not doing that I want
to stay on the flats yes so he has to
smack the horse in the ass and yank it
over and now the horse now I'm and now
I'm up on top of nowhere and I and I'm
I'm Galloping where I have no none no
business doing yeah and I almost fall
off three times yeah horses are no jokes
yeah it's no joke and uh then where did
you guys stay at a hotel yeah stayed in
hotel ten days is too long
it's just too long and it wasn't
relaxing
and it was I was learning a lot but even
for me to learn for 10 days a little too
much four days of learning is good and
then once your brain goes we're good
dude yeah how is it that that's that's
the wall real depressing depressing well
my so is my face but anyway I look like
you know what you know what you look
like Kim I look a little bit like a
camel yeah you look just like a kid but
that's the camera that's the angle of it
no it's just it's just you have similar
features of camel dude am I a camel yeah
that's all it's whatever it's not a
terrible thing it is a terrible thing
that's bad angles same teeth all good
um what were you saying
B let's take a little break I'm in
Covina here in Covina Covina Covina
Covina I mean yeah
Thursday Friday Saturday brand new I'm
at that new new it's a little theater
out there in Covina California
again I freak out how do you say Covina
Covina Covina Covina it's not Covina
Covina because Covina would be Nia there
it is new Laugh Factory this little
theater they just bought out there so it
should be pretty dope it's that Nunu
come get some this Thursday Friday
Saturday David Lucas will be with me
come get some fam take that thick
boy.com new merch also available new
baseball jerseys you have to pinstripe
your boys rocking out you got gray you
got hoodies got hats get some at
thickboy.com but I will see you guys
this week
uh Comedy Works Denver downtown Denver
this weekend Thursday Friday Saturday
come get some Greenville South Carolina
Comedy Zone July 7 8 and then Blue Room
Springfield Missouri July 20 21 22. God
bless let's rock and roll now listen I
need some nuts man my energy is low dude
dude but here's the thing I spent all my
money trying to uh climb out of kung fu
trying to climb out whatever no too much
money I can't afford you need energy but
you need a you need something that keeps
I know dude but I'm not a billionaire
how do I get macadamia nuts uh House of
macadamias well tell me more all right
fine they they work with about 95
Farmers so they're they they work with a
support Farmers they've got the best
macadamia nuts from South Africa on the
planet which is why they can give them
to you at a price that you would that is
a fraction of what you pay at a lot of
different stores they are the best
they've got rare Omega seven fatty acids
how about the dip Macadamia dip white
chocolate dipped in the regular
chocolate dip Raspberry Vanilla oh a lot
of people are into Anthony age and take
them a lot of people want to live
forever I don't even care about that
they're so delicious I eat them because
they're delicious I don't care about how
healthy if they were bad for me I'd eat
them they're so good they are how about
their creamy nut Butters that the cold
pressed extra virgin Macadamia Oil
believable oh my God cook with it I was
cooking dude how about the snack bars
daddy we got snack bars all over here we
got blueberry coconut white chocolate
plain chocolate my mouth is watered
dipped in that chocolate you got to try
fave yeah and they never give discounts
what they're doing for the fire kid Army
House of macadamias are doing a very
special deal for the d5k friends for
limit time they're giving you guys a
free box of 45 Macadamia snack bars one
of each flavor so you get a variety of
all the tasty flavors when you visit
House of macadamias.com tfak plus 20 off
your entire order of delicious
macadamias that's 20 off when you use
the code tfak teeth House
of macadamias.com tfak to himself in a
free pack of nut bars yeah
well anyway so I'm glad to be back in
the United States of America you piece
of [__]
I really am
I just am Everybody's Got a Gun there
out there oh yeah it's just everybody's
at War yeah all the time everybody's
ready there's a lot of rock throwing
right a lot of rock a lot of a lot of
American you see a lot of shady
Americans there a lot of shady special
ops I bet yeah I bet I didn't go on
vacation I didn't work I was in uh
Denver on Wednesday night met up with
our boy Aaron Rodgers and Aubry and then
I went to the Psychedelic convention
wasn't aware I was going to be part of
that okay did you do any psychedelic
sprinting no you did not no okay
nope uh and then if you if you did do
second talks what would probably be what
would be the most likely thing that you
would have done
oh
maybe mushrooms yeah it was like a
mushroom conference
but I had uh we're in the green room and
there's some mushroom expert like
showing like slides and and there was
five thousand people five thousand
people I just got a job he's like the
mushroom expert I walk in the Green Room
this guy's bombing and they were
laughing so I guess he's like the guy I
went I went hey the Shaman's eating [__]
out there man right they're laughing so
hard I thought I'd be like dude that
guy's like a living legend I know but he
needs some punch up on his jokes [__]
huh you just you know I've been doing
one of those oh yeah where their
medicine they're they talk about plant
medicine I'm like Aubrey and Aaron
Rodgers they were cool because they just
got there and talked and Roger's talking
about how it's helped him and stuff like
that so theirs was entertaining but
before that boring how does it helped
him yes yeah yeah yo man when he's
football yo man when he breaks it down
yeah when he started how many touchdowns
he's thrown since it's nuts is that true
that's what I said to him yeah yeah nuts
okay I don't believe it but no I promise
yeah I know you promise
[Music]
yeah but he shows the numbers before and
then after it's I'm telling you that's
true facts yeah yeah facts he has a
whole the whole thing yeah yeah I mean I
mean I feel like he would know what did
he say about that what was it about that
that did it for him just like it helped
him connect with people and open up his
mind to like certain connections because
he has a lot of childhood trauma stuff
like that oh wow yeah like it really
opened up his mind to different things
and did he do it with somebody like a
shot oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah would
you ever do that I would do that yeah I
would do that yeah once it went South
very badly yeah I don't know if you deal
with the right people don't remember any
of it yeah yeah well I did too much yeah
yeah yeah but uh I told them that story
and they're all laughing that's really
hard yeah it's the real is the joke of
the night to be honest well I mean yeah
we had dinner at Elway's but just a good
dude man we got a project we're working
on and then I left from there and then
Thursday I went to Alice dude Glenn Beck
when's Last Summer heard that name Glenn
Beck well I was a fan still I was a fan
he was at Fox left Fox bro is that the
blaze he owns the place bro
when I say his studios are the best
studio I've ever I've been we've been in
the studios yeah any like podcasts like
no dude so he bought the whole Paramount
lot oh boy oh in Dallas in Dallas did
you meet him uh no he wasn't there when
I was there okay but uh dude you walk in
and uh they drop me off I'm like what
the [__] it's like a movie lot like this
is a podcasting he's like yeah just go
through there checking out the gate you
walk in there's a Bentley old school
Bentley three million dollars he has
like a bunch of old he likes to collect
old things three million dollar Bentley
in the lobby I'm like oh my God this is
nuts it has like all these artifacts all
this stuff dude the sets was then the
staff I've never seen anything like it
really I was like oh my God and one of
the guys I was doing the show with David
he goes how big is your student I heard
thick boys go on oh yeah it's cool
um so you see where like your uh like um
little like coffee areas he goes yeah to
the Bentley he's yeah it's about that
big he's like oh interesting yeah
they're just like you're talking 40 foot
ceiling nuts wow nuts [__] so impressed
that's really cool Glenn Beck is my
North Star now I mean it's nuts well
maybe you just went Fox see ya we make a
move and you just did all his oh we go
to Dallas Fort Worth is the move because
I stayed at this hotel you know me I
love hotels yeah there's Hotel Emma then
there's Hotel drover brother Hotel drove
don't say my daddy's always in Dallas
you'll love this hotel drover now it's
in Fort Worth so it's about 30 minutes
outside Dallas dude but it's on this so
they have like it's like this dope hotel
but on the premises like Hotel Emma
across the street is the rodeo rodeos
every Friday and Saturday then they have
the livestock over here and there's just
a strip of
Cowboy [__] like nice steakhouses and
bars it was so cool man I was just
walking around exploring yeah top three
hotels I've ever stayed in really
amazing amazing the whole area is just
so dope and it's hidden you pull in
you're like oh my god well you know what
you realize there's money in Dallas oh
big boy big boy money old school oil
money like crazy crazy wow that looks
yeah I was just walking around I was so
nice I mean you're talking about America
you're talking about the best that
America has to offer in a lot of ways
it's nice yeah it was fun
um it was fun out there you had a good
podcast yeah yeah I did the normal world
where they do I think they just started
so they do three episodes on YouTube and
then it's behind the paywatch so the
blaze is all beyond the paywall yes okay
like it's kind of like daily Wire yeah
it's all Glenn Beck's thing like
everything he does he monetizes books
everything he monetized every single
conservative you know
like ecosystem oh dude
seems to be pushing more people in that
direction you see a setup but mind
blowing mind-blowing wow never seen like
it wow I call my grandma if I ever got
Glenn Beck's money I would build the
exact same Studio I would call whoever
the engineers are like build it just
like Glenn Beck wow
Jesus nuts how many shows does he have
on the Block well I couldn't I don't I
don't even know he has hit like you walk
in his Studios right there it's all
glass real you know professional yeah
and then you go back to Studio One
there's seven you go to back to Studio
One now they remember it's Paramount so
they shoot they shot the RoboCop movies
there the old school robocops row cop
one Rogue cop two Barney was shot out of
there some parts of Indiana Jones like
it's Paramount I bet you they're talking
to uh Tucker Carlson I mean everybody is
right yeah if that's what Tucker wants
to do 100 yeah there's stupid money in
that because he there's no way he's
making I'm maybe Twitter's paying him a
fee you look at the views he's getting
I'm sure he's getting a fee from Twitter
people to buy behind a paywall right
it's the views the viewership's not to
talk anybody cares about the viewership
right so that he he can go off into his
Glenn Beck thing and make all the money
how long were you in Texas for just a
day oh that's it just well I I flew in
that morning dude you went to that you
went to Austin first no I didn't go to
Austin you didn't because I remember I
was gonna meet Aubry and uh Aaron
Rodgers in Austin yeah he's like hey we
got to be in Denver for this convention
meet us there I'm like I need a reason
to come to Denver so I flew to Denver
how long were you there the night just a
night I got an 11 then left the next
morning for Dallas at 11 I was in Dallas
that night on Thursday night and flew
back daily on Friday you stay with your
brother no no no Hotel yeah
because I was there for business I
didn't hang out with anybody
that's great but yeah Dallas was cool I
could live in Dallas
oh yeah
we might
I'm up for anything buddy you never know
you never know Daddy gone through some
changes might as well Jake sniff it out
and ain't no thanks just a hurricane
yeah this Hurricane
old school bro old school old school
yeah back to what we do true man now you
shaved your head a little bit well it
was getting long on the sides just the
sides just the side right here out in
the back there no still puffy all right
all right I don't mind you when you're
when you're scruffy yeah thanks Doug
yeah looker very very very common
haircut out there in Dallas I was not
aware I looked like every cowboy out
there yeah I was like oh okay well yeah
that's fine
you talk football with Aaron
barely we talked about CU but not really
we talked about literally everything
else but football great guy such a good
person yeah great guy
playing 17 years dude isn't that crazy
not so long at the level he's playing at
nuts how big is he about your size
uh big thinner uh yeah about my height
six three six four Jesus yeah he's no
punk no
no no punk but not a thing not thick no
he's not thinking big legs yeah but not
like a thick guy no
225 okay yeah who knows super stud great
person
um I'm sure you saw the news with Elon
Musk and uh Mark Zuckerberg yeah now now
can I tell you how I coach him well
first of all before I even get into that
[__] the coaching
um I like how
how give me your thoughts on this how
Dana goes this isn't a gimmick fight
this fight would do more numbers than
any other fight I've ever produced I'm
like you're confusing people watching it
can people get a lot of people can watch
a fight but still a gimmick this is a
the biggest gimmick the UFC's ever been
Associated without a doubt CM Punk
Brock Lesnar someone would say give him
became Champions what about two guys who
are you're talking about two guys hey
they're way past their Prime aren't
competitive any facet and you're calling
this not a gimmick I don't know why I
didn't call it what it is hey clear it's
a gimmick if they're gonna do it might
as well do it with UFC I'm the best
throne in the world we could figure
something out but to come back like this
isn't a gimmick a gimmick's a UFC
fighter versus a boxer and this and you
also said you want to do that this is
going to be and this is going to be a an
MMA fight MMA fight in the UFC well you
know first I'll tell you right now bro
yeah yeah I hate to cut all the wind out
of ourselves this has never happened the
fight's never gonna happen it's never
gonna happen it's never happening I
guarantee it doesn't happen well first
can you imagine have you ever seen Elon
Musk with his shirt off well he's have
you ever seen what is it Mark Zuckerberg
sweat he's a robot well
well there are a couple problems Mark
Zuckerberg is a very small man and Elon
is a giant man he's probably about six
two I've seen one person I'm gonna give
him six three no easy he's 6-3 with tits
oh he's tall he remember he's but you
think everybody's big he's Dutch no he's
Dutch he's six more than that he's I'm
telling you he's bigger see I I I I've
six two three means a lot there's no way
he's bigger than six to be there's no
way man he's so much heavier than than
200 pounds
that what is that is a weird thing to
say because he's way bigger
here you know what this fight's never
happened bring up Elon Musk and Joe
Rogan take a look at this watch I'm
telling you he's not big I've seen him
in person too yeah he's not six three
he's nowhere near eye level with me
nowhere near
no no
let's see where they're standing
together if there's a picture of them
he's in the back here
see how much taller he is there so
obviously yeah
so that's a terrible yeah here we go
this is better
so and Chappelle's not huge either well
spells Chappelle is about six foot yeah
I mean if that's taller actually no six
one so he lands at least six two dude I
don't think so I don't think so he's got
a big head there he is he's
significantly taller look at his
shoulders Bob see where his shoulders
are yeah there's big head big head he's
big guy compared to compared to
Zuckerberg it's tiny yes
165. yeah so so here's what here's what
Zuckerberg can do ankle Locker get
behind him and try to choke him Elon
Musk has to jab him or front kick him in
the [__] head
I mean Zuckerberg's also a lot older I
mean uh Elon musk's a lot older yeah and
then also you're assuming he can even
throw a front kick then also yeah that's
a big that's a big assumption now
Russell's my hype bub Russell's my
height John Favreau is a big
guy's not tall bring about tall fabric
but but dude I've been with Russell how
many times Michelle and I are about the
Sam Hyde Russell it's five eleven look
at how much taller look at how much
taller yeah 6-1 John Favreau look at
Elon come on he's a lot taller that's
why I'm giving him six three no he's not
six three go back to that picture I
don't know what else you need but B who
knows what shoes they're with Russell's
five eleven but who knows what shoes
they're even if they're wearing the same
shoes
in Boots like he always is he always
wears black boots how many more how many
how many more inches is Elon taller than
look at where his shoulders are and
where Kanye's Kanye's not even six foot
five tens five nine five ten yeah he's
not he's not six three B
well I mean I don't know what else you
need to see you're seeing him next to
John five row he's a lot taller no we
don't know what shoes they're wearing
dude you're smarter than this even if
they're wearing Elon with giant boots
he wears platform boots dude
it's not there he's not
what do you mean where's platform boots
is that a fact yes he would he always
wears these giant black boots dude
now Jordan Peterson's go back to that
Bubba Jordan Peterson like look at his
shoes he's wearing shoes
I don't know why you're arguing about
this look how much taller he is than
Rogan and Jordan Peterson
how tall is Jordan Peterson Jordan isn't
six too
I mean he said how tall he is
I mean I don't know why we're having
this argument
the guy is look how much taller he is
okay look how much taller he is than
Jordan Peterson look I've I mean I've
seen him up close and personal he's he's
that picture proves it
doesn't it which one the one we were
just at
e and we were just at the one with uh
with Jordan Peterson I gotta go back
yeah
either way he's way bigger than Mark
Zuckerberg he's bigger so let's say six
two B what's your [__] point six
three
he's six three he's look at him look at
him so he almost told her because then
Brogan come on
Zuckerberg is about the same size so
height wise not thickness
so elon's just way bigger than Mark
Zuckerberg it's the point I'm making way
bigger heavier bigger and everything but
everyone knows that b literally every
single platform that you just said
everyone says elon's bigger we all know
this so so point is point is I think
he's just too big for Mark well who's
more skilled though Marksman training
he trains with Mikey musheshi all each
like he trains still what's the on
training yeah think about what you just
said yeah but it's just Jitsu yeah Elon
doesn't train in anything yeah well he'd
have to train
but the point is he doesn't one guy's
been training for years
this is the freak Show yeah think about
it you don't think it's ever happening
not a chance this fight happens why it's
just not having it you think it's just
all publicity yes and didn't want to be
part of it he's a [__] that's all
he's doing he likes that his name's
involved in it it's never happening it
has to be an expedition exhibition match
so it's not gonna happen there what is
that the weight difference so it can't
be professional who would clarify it of
a guy who's to your point six seven two
hundred pounds versus Mark Zuckerberg
who's 155. so there's gonna be a 50
pound weight difference
they're both o and O it's not happening
dude
I think it'd be so ugly to see me too
and then and then how how far of a
gimmick do you want to go is it three
two minute rounds is it three five
minute rounds that would make it better
is if Kamala Harris tag teamed in I'll
be down for that you know there's AOC
yeah pretty cool I'd love to see that oh
no AOC versus Candace Owens oh can
someone's beat the [__] up all of the
[__] out of all including the almost 100
percent
yeah I just don't I mean it's fun to I
guess it's fun to talk about so insane
we can talk about it but um it's insane
it's insane it's insane that we're
talking about I think I think Dana
missed the ball going as this isn't a
gimmick you're like oh papa no we're not
that stupid don't be wrong I'm stupid
I'm not that stupid clearly this is the
biggest game all the time no I don't
like it you don't like I don't like any
of it no I think it puts a little
Unbecoming I think it's the black guy in
the sport it's just it's just so amateur
level it's so amateur level the UFC
should not be part of it it's called
spectacle yeah that's all it is like all
you're doing is capitalizing on this
stupid Specter look up look up the
definition of spectacle because it's not
a good it's never happening I I think it
just goes to show how bored Dana is with
booking real fights yeah well he does
power slap Fight League he's doing this
uh
a visually striking performance because
I've never seen regarded in terms of its
visual impact it's all about just visual
now don't get me wrong is he gonna do
numbers yeah 100 so would Brad Pitt and
uh George Clooney yeah it doesn't matter
so two hot girls fighting it doesn't
make it it doesn't mean it should be in
the UFC that's right and also name
another organization let's say Mark and
Elon had a background in basketball yeah
you can you imagine if they called up
David the NBA went hey we'd love if
during the listen during the All-Star
Game the dunk contest we're gonna play
one-on-one will you guys broadcast it on
TNT they'd go absolutely not that we
can't do that yeah it would diminish our
brand we can't do that yes he's going
we'll do it we need attention I think
what's interesting about really rich
people so they're they're billions to
think that they can fight well that but
also they that like you realize that
when you have that much money you get so
bored that you want to go to space go 16
000 feet under the water or get in a
fight in the Octagon like anything to
feel alive because you you just can't
get your rocks off you're that poor like
money like material things don't do it
you're willing to fight another genius
inside the Octagon think about it you
want to go see the Titanic even though
the boat was made by the eight-year-old
it's also it's also I think no one's
immune to wanting to be famous and no
one's me to wanting to be relevant
nobody's how famous how much Fame do you
these guys are famous to [__] but that's
that's it's like a director friend of
mine who said
she had she was working with a couple of
actresses and this very famous agent
said never underestimate
ever underestimate the the
size of the attention hole that an
actress wants to feel like they want all
the attention and more than you can
imagine when you're working with these
big stars what got them to the dance a
lot of times was that whole is I've had
my experience with this with stars who
have a pathological need to suck up all
the energy they have to pay all the
attention to the point where they'll
date somebody it has nothing to do with
there as long as they're in the in the
Limelight oh we know a lot of people
yeah they want the light on them yeah
yeah it's just it's in it's all insane
if you're Elon it Zuckerberg's like yes
I have all the money especially Elon
dude you're pretty well known you bought
Twitter you went to Mars with a shirt
off because I want to take a look at
this again
well then we're gonna do for the testing
you know what I'm saying is it
there's a lot of variables I think he's
that's a thick fella
that's a pig
then it says white he's got to get a tan
I think Mark would be the I mean I I
think you might gas out I think Elon
beat the [__] out I think Elon has that
immigrant that Giants that Dutch
strength yeah I I feel like Elon grown
up probably had some you know he's
autistic so he probably had some fights
in his life mark uh-huh has never fought
anything yeah
yeah Elon is just a giant you saw the
thick South African men it's a lot of
that's a lot of bone and muscle to move
around right it's a big barrel chest
hey take it easy these are both [__]
right let's take it take you down a
notch this is part of the perspective
how about how boy Putin
bring food now see him over there don't
[__] with food he'll give you a beat
he's got some tests but he'll [__] you
up
Black Mountain Judo I guarantee you can
punch you in the face and it's taking a
couple of lives that's a gangster
that's a gangster
on a [__] horse now getting through
as far as dictators goes yeah
yeah he walks any Judo gym in America
you get this [__] mop with on the
floor don't get it twisted he's the most
powerful gangster in the world yeah
correct you know what I mean at the same
time Judy almost got overthrown that was
fun I couldn't stop watching oh fast I
was like no way but also like what
happened like what did they settled they
paid them off now though is in Belarus
in Exile problem is the president of
Belarus is in Putin's back pocket that's
Putin's puppet so this General because I
give him 60 days tops he's 100 was like
you know it's all good oh you take oh no
no we won't touch you no yeah oh you're
in Belarus fantastic
yes let me know if you need Hotel rats
yeah yeah it's not going to be we're
gonna need some Hotel it's a very weird
thing oh dude there's some thoughts
about the Americans paid off progression
who knows but no or the Americans were
helping him yeah but he also has the
Wagner group's also the most badass
they've been fighting yeah they're
they're I don't think they can win the
Ukraine crane War without those guys no
but now Putin's like you don't want it
too but I get like Elon and a lot of
people have said be careful what you ask
for because they overthrow Elon I'm
sorry if they overthrow boom it's worse
it gets worse and they have access to
all the nukes all the like you're
dealing with some serious consequences
you don't want to be careful what you
ask correct like yeah you want putting
out who's gonna step in correct and not
a good way worse you know they got you
know the guy who who runs the Wagner
group you know how he got famous right
who's this Chef yeah it was like I got a
ton of money [__] this criminal too oh
straight oh dude bad guy it was rap it
was rap you know what you don't do you
don't almost overthrow oh no because
it's suicide almost like you ever seen
valerique
yeah like he's like dude we can try this
yeah we're gonna try this uh you know we
can try this Heist there but if it goes
we're all gonna die and how's that end
they all get shot in the face that's
right and hung yeah and they asked Putin
they said what is the one thing that you
never forget he said treachery oh you
don't want that yeah
treachery it was fascinating the ones
going down you got that and then you got
the the submarine submarine thing's
interesting right and this just shows
you how crooked the buy-ins are they
knew they everybody knew that was close
to situation on Sunday that that boat
imploded going into the depths of the
ocean on Sunday 90 minutes into their
exploring the Titanic that's right they
knew for a fact 90 minutes but they knew
Hunter Biden's information ones get
released this week but they could Trump
that and this would be make all the
Headway if they just let it go so think
of the families the hope the hope and oh
they only do uh Thursday morning they
run out of air think of that [__] think
about what's evil that is also is that
social media was like yeah billionaires
let them die how terrible laughing it's
like hey [__] because they're
billionaires how terrible was that what
are you talking about you know how hard
it is become a billionaire doesn't mean
you're an evil person no it means you're
better at [__] than you are and also the
in the 19 year old son on there and he
didn't want to go his reservation about
going they convince him to go and then
two guys had a lot of nautical
experience and they said those guys with
as many Dives as they've done submarines
like they said when it imploded it
happened in milliseconds like they would
be like what boom over right but they
said those two guys have been on all
those missions knew before it was
happening like they did they said the
sounds that the the submarine was making
they knew they're [__] really
and then before before we got Honey dick
by the bidens in the media that shows
you how corrupt the media when are
people going to realize that the media
is not on our side it's all propaganda
when are you gonna [__] open your
eyes quit being cheap like just look up
just look at this and think about the
oxygen then start thinking they said
they're gonna auction on Thursday
morning right that's their critical time
but that's auction banking on five
people do you think let's say this
hypothetically didn't implode on Sunday
do you think there's a conversation
that they're like all right well five if
all five is here we're gonna die on
Thursday but if there's two we're gonna
level we have a better chances like you
talk about hey we're gonna have to kill
half of you well the one thing is you
can't move very well in there you're you
can't stretch out I don't know oh no
someone's gonna have to volunteer to go
you can't you can't stretch out and also
it's super dark and super cool freezing
so they actually got off easy because
that's the best case scenario they said
because if not they ran auction it's
it's torture B that the bottom of the
ocean it's freezing it's like it's like
it's like the as cold as the the moon
and then it's you're in pitch dark look
at that
look at that no thanks I can't believe
they they volunteered to go
you're freezing you know what you know
James Cameron has been down like 33
times the Titanic yeah and he builds so
he's been there he builds Subs because
he has all the money Bill Subs he goes I
only do it three times and I get rid of
him this one hasn't been serviced in how
long how many dies five yeah which is
like unheard of and he's like I knew as
soon as I saw him they imploded on sun
the minute they left they died that day
because I knew all the media was running
with all this narrative I knew Sunday
they all died
terrible how about this what did you
come on implodes yeah yeah but how about
and then it's so hot it gets the it's
like the sun surface it's so hot yeah
why from all all the pressure like 12
000 nuts
turned into mush like liquid they said
just just mush them up
that quick milliseconds so you can't
even blink and see it it's how fast it
went so I just went how about this how
about what the Billionaire's wife her
two great grandparents both died on the
Titanic
oh that's why
and the one guy was the guy who's had
this 19 year old son was obsessed with
the Titanic stuff obsessed
it's all tragic man it's terrible now
what's even more interesting is do you
know there's a boat off of I forget
where you have to look it up Jen of 600
refugees
and they put all the resources in this
Titanic destination the submarine that
they knew imploded they knew the the
experts knew Sunday morning that 90
minutes into the dive they all died but
there were 600 refugees lost at sea and
they didn't send out any help they knew
tears of Justice buddy
and they knew Kodak Black the rapper my
buddy says lawyer Kodak rap the guy
forgot three years you got three years
for what Hunter Biden got a misdemeanor
for same charge
and the Biden stuff if somebody could
please explain as this tweet said how
all his family has all these millions of
dollars with all these shell companies
for all for adding no value for I mean
100 Biden didn't know [__] about there
it is 600 migrants drowned near Greece
they drowned oh they all died 600. what
and we put all the resources into
finding this fake submarine that was
already imploded yeah dude
and because the families of those people
are like hold on how are you not putting
any resources into this or the millions
of dollars you wasted and you knew that
they all died but you could continued on
with this [__] circus but about all
the 600 people 100 people among them are
between 30 and 100 children all dead
didn't send any resource
that looks insane
terrible
oh my god dude so many bodies have been
recovered the majority of the Dead are
likely still trapped in the hole at the
bottom of one of its deepest parts of
the Mediterranean just 104 survivors
have been rescued search called off
Friday night
oh man
they just put half the resources into
the people that died on Sunday who knows
how many they could have saved if any
but still
you see any news coverage of this
anything
survivors is essentially a capsized
during an attempt to tow it
the Coast Guard now admit they added
Mooring line attached but insist there
was no effort to tug the boat
because they didn't know how to pull the
Rope The Vessel started tilting right
and left
the Coast Guard boat is going too fast
but the vessel is already tilt in the
left and that's how it sank
dark [__] man
yeah
I don't want a diet see
no I mean you could offered me to see
the Titanic for free and I would not go
are you out of your [__] mind you
want to go down how deep thousand feet
that's deeper than blue whales go oh I'm
okay get the [__] how far how far down
do blue whales go
well not not far at all no they went 12
000 feet that's so crazy it's two miles
down are you out of your mind two miles
down
come on
holy [__] but it's not sixteen thousand
they can dive but look they they see
they're usually depth of less than 330
feet yeah they're usually chilling at 3
30.
yeah
I have no desire and you know if you
just go to the uh The Mirage in Vegas
has like a bunch of old piece from the
Titanic you can get all the crab legs
you need hire a pro for a thousand fun
night that's all check out the Titanic
crab legs and a pro
and there's no risk huh what are we
doing come on man
play some crabs back on the plane the
next morning yeah I I'm not interested
in going to space or going that deep in
the water I'm just not in the submarine
I don't give a [__] hey bring up
pictures of the Titanic watch this ready
there's the other thing I'm saying I've
been taking pictures in Petra because
there are better pictures if I can
Google it don't don't send it to me
watch this
all right that's it right there you
wanna on the bottom of the ocean yeah on
the bottom not sure fully upright that's
it that's what you see by the way you're
not seeing much more than that
you need your light and stuff but I mean
that's depressing look at that [__]
thing
look at that thing at the bottom of the
ocean dude have you ever seen this
update you know the Titanic's not even
as big as cruise ships that we have
today I mean not your fraction is big no
it's not big at all dude really compared
to the boats that you see on cruise
ships or the docks you could bring up
bring up uh size of Titanic compared to
modern day boats not that big it's not
that impressive
there you go size Titanic compared to
modern day cruise ships
you go ahead and click on that picture
chin at the top there this one yep she
whiz
what you didn't know that did you I sure
as heck didn't not that impressive is it
no yeah Disney has bigger cruise ships
than the Titans compared to that thing
yeah it's a [__] that's a tugboat
today
oh boy look at that little piece of [__]
yeah
wow
the more you know
the more you know not that impressive
now back in 1912 it is now the family
for next year wants to go on a cruise
around the Mediterranean kill me
kill me hey does your dad go what's the
stupidest [__] we can do well okay does
Papa Cowan go what's gonna board
everyone to [__] well as long as
you've got a beach though right
restaurants on the cruise ship I mean
when it docks for the day then you're
dumbassing in background goes and you
gotta get on
and then you're back on the hotel
it's a hotel on the [__] yeah that
would be in one place huh
oh
but a lot a lot of those uh billionaire
stuff like that like we need them like a
lot of them hey they do get bored but
they do a lot of you know climb Mount
Everest and have you ever looked up how
many people have died just last year
doing this extreme [__] you see that
[__] with like Mount Everest past you
see the body sliding past that
the woman on just recently on Mount
Everest it happens all the time I've
died and they just went sliding for sure
but there's them people 88 people died
in Everest last year more people died in
Everest people die in Grand Canyon all
the time uh surfing like happens not
like these extremists it's what you sign
up for that's right unfortunately
especially this is my thing if you're
that billionaire but that submarine
can't be too much for you
create your own that safe dude why would
you trust these [__] idiots how would
you not do any due diligence go hey once
you give that a once over before we jump
two miles under the sea two miles under
the sea I'm a billionaire dude
for you to look for everything Shack for
cracks and they they had uh one of the
engineers even was like Hey this thing's
only five inches thick should be seven
they're cutting Corners here to get it
cheaper this is not safe and he got uh
sued and because he voided his NDA yeah
there's been a bunch of people like
complaining about the service
they call right now hey Brandon every
time I'm finding the kid we'd love to
offer you and Brian one trip to check
out the Titanic there go absolutely not
now you want to get out of your mind Hey
we'd pay you 250 Grand absolutely not no
and these dumbasses paid 250 Grand
nah
nuts
yeah I chin went to uh Hong Kong
went to Korea okay I went to Korea I'm
gonna need you to get your [__] I
thought he went to Bulls
earlier you know he's Korean can you
please respect the difference it's a
running bit me and Jim Medina I keep
picking different Chinese
Taiwanese Japanese Korean all very do
you do any fashion out there chin they
got a good fashion out there speaking of
fashion I got you guys some gifts here
what
so these are all the rage in Korea no
joke
um
which color do you guys prefer uh give
Brennan the pink it's not in pink it's
like that's a pink peach or something
that's a it's a samurai it's a samurai
pink if I've ever seen it so these are
because you know skin care is really
important in Korea is there a lot of sun
out there I mean they they just really
care about skincare oh we're people
still were people still a mask out there
mass and then do you guys been rocking
math since the 60s what's up you guys
been rocking math since the 60s
oh it's snap
chin you really went all out I did here
you go oh snap it's all the rage in
Korea
that looks dope dude Georgie's bucket
hats cool
we see how much it protects you
especially the summer's coming it's
gonna get hot
not today
do they ever fold it up like this you
can do whatever you want yeah I'll use
this I want to protect yourself you look
like a pilgrim well I look like a a lady
I look like a nun no you look like you
look you look like uh it's a flying
habit no you look like you're on a you
look like you're on a horse house in
hand made stale yeah yeah I look like a
handmade looks like you own a whorehouse
and hands made yeah
I'm a handmade and you're gonna [__] me
yeah
in that thing
this is great [__] yeah thanks General
you're welcome
um feels good no sun buddy I feel like
Georgia got a cool bucket hat
I got the other guy's bucket hats too
but those that's all there is what are
you doing right yeah because I haven't
slept but wait yeah
um I want a bucket yo what if I want the
bug next time I go to Korea next time
yeah next time
but these are going off Amazon come on
dude how is Korea it was amazing yeah it
was some weird [__] what's up you eat
some weird [__]
yeah raw I'll show you right now I write
raw octopus raw oh was it alive it was
it with the tentacles like yep he's a
piece of [__] it's not a piece of [__]
that's a beer
here
either so you can see
you're flying that's airplane food no
it's not first it's air premier which is
like a hybrid to the motherland
economy-ish which in our first ever
night on the town in Korea
Korea's badass yeah yeah Korea is
awesome it's so technologically advanced
so this Marketplace is so dope there's
tons of places out there are they two
days ahead of us one day dude look at
that
look at the difference between so that's
raw beef that's raw beef right there
which is delicious
all those are live I've had all that
some of the best food in the world take
it easy a little bit huh is that your
dad that's my dad yeah some of the best
food in the world dude in Korea that
that Marketplace must be so stupid
you're gonna go to that in Singapore and
you're gonna love it Singapore that's
not going to any of them
dude when you go there you feel like
you're in a different dimension in the
world it's so like you're in spider
verse it's just like when we went to
Europe and uh Australia and yeah Ireland
Australia I felt just a cleaner
yeah I don't know I stuck out so crazy
in Korea I stuck out so crazy people
were like I thought by now there's like
so many different tall people in Korea I
still stuck out like crazy yeah you're
enormous yeah they upgraded my Airbnb
when the host saw me because she felt
bad that I was so big oh how was the
living quarters it was small so they
gave me a bigger Arabian are you uh
you're a single man right
yeah did the ladies check you out what
do you think Brian he's too big I think
so yeah the tattoos you're kind of a big
dude and you have that you have an
accent you have that American accent oh
you do have an American accent oh cowboy
did you say oh Cowboy chin
oh Cowboy chin
Cowboy chin oh Cowboy chin that's what
they call them dude ask them
did they call you Cowboy chin no babe
did you did you did you did you uh I
know the answer is no but I'm gonna ask
you anyways did you hook up with any
Kareem Naja also my family
yeah but couldn't you but hey I'm gonna
go for a walk and check out some of the
hall houses
I don't think there's whorehouses there
hey
it's not like Japan hey come on dude
that looks badass right now hell yeah
dude that's great hell yeah there's more
houses out there all right well I guess
that's it a little salty and [__]
all right what do you got chin uh
there's not a ton of stuff out right now
but let's see well someone set this in
t5k army
give me a sec so it's oh yeah Joe
Exotica for president too but then look
at the guy next to him they say this is
Chappelle which I think normally I
wouldn't say that it's a little bit
racist but
maybe I can kind of see a little bit of
it yeah
yeah maybe similar smile I thought he
died oh man Joe Exotic yeah no well he
has cancer
does he yeah yeah he had cancer and he
still does
hmm looks like he's thriving though
what is that outfit I don't know
so Greg Abbott
the governor of Texas he uh posted
something on Twitter about this fake
news article with uh Garth Brooks
so this is what he wrote so apparently
Garth Brooks he has a new bar he's not
gonna you know ban the Bud Light No he
posted you know his new bar and we're
serving Bud Light I'm like oh you don't
know you're right A lot of people are
pro you know a lot of people don't like
that obviously oh no no no so Greg
Abbott saw this like fake article about
it about how people booed him on stage
or whatever but that never happened and
then it was obviously a fake article so
he had deleted it right after so he got
made fun of somebody's going to a Garth
Brook concert to boo him no dude no I
mean he has the big the car yes even
today we don't really hear about him but
he's so messed up even if half his fan
base are like Bud Light we're out he's
still bawling yeah
but this is what uh Greg Abbott wrote
go woke go bro Garth call this
conservative fans [__] good job
Texas and then he linked the article
which was a fake article so he deleted
her right after he'll be a certain age
to be tweeting
um Georgie you got this one yeah fan
sent this in this is a 18 foot long
Burmese python that ate an American
alligator hell yeah
and why'd they kill him uh I think
they're because they're invasive species
oh this is Florida [__] huge python
massive 18 feet
that alligator was like dude you could
have saved me an hour ago
that's a giant python dude that's so
cool sucks they killed him though yeah
but they belong in Burma where they have
natural enemies
damn you just swallowed that alligator
hole
don't they usually die when they try to
eat something how crazy is that yeah
swallowed the whole [__] alligator
holy [__] and then this one too this was
a self-defense training course not
really but a beautiful display of
self-defense
every single day what's he doing there
oh he's just gotta move let him go okay
hey give up give up drop the lighter
I will let him down in three seconds
okay
he's out he's out he's out he's out
about to end up like that poor dude on
the New York sub what do you do that how
do you do that a rare naked choke it
looks the difference it's not this yeah
he's just choking like a bulldog stupid
choke like this yeah man
but he's putting his and he's putting
his body against his head yeah I mean
the old school even I can't tell what
kind of joke that was it's like I don't
know yeah don't act like it he's just
doing this
right but he's just squeezing here the
guy has nobody's also putting his head
where's his there's a way to please he
was literally just doing this
and putting his
nice little Gable Grill cable grip
well he just leaves out yeah and we were
trying to look up the story but
apparently the oh we could hear is like
you know giving back his lighters he
took his lighter maybe he stole his
lighter you see what he's doing there
yeah she's just grabbing his arm and
just pulling
that's
um
I don't know why he said I'm hold on for
three seconds he's already out though
man he actually pet his head dude two
times afterwards
pattern his head
uh Tony bro trains every day every day
oh this is pretty crazy hell yeah this
is crazy shark attack I haven't seen
this dude you haven't oh [__] this so
these are just fishermen and this is
what happens when the guy puts his hand
in the water outside of the boat is
there a bull shark or something yeah
they think it's they don't know for a
fact that they think it's a bull shark
that's exactly
I guess his friends like don't put your
hand in the water
dumbass simple as that dude I wouldn't
why would you ever put your hand why
would he why would you put his hand in
the water I don't know he was just
trying to grab him did you get a feel
go back go back play again
no let me just see the club the the
where let me just let me see this oh the
PSA the still of what though if you go
down Jim it's not still there it is that
[__] thing that's a bull shark bro
just bit him thought it was a fish yes
sharks don't shark [__] man why would
you oh so you know uh
what that that tiger shark that killed
that man in Egypt
so that tiger shark they think was there
because there's a boat that was dropping
[__] uh chump sheep off they would it
was like a Slaughter boat or something
and it was dropping the carcasses off
and the Sharks would follow the [__]
boat and then like a swimming yeah and
the the whatever they think the shark
one of the Sharks kind of got
distracted or got taken and and they
they were doing that in the shark saw
what looked like a sheep and just
attacked it they've been conditioned to
eat something like that oh it's an
excuse right oh the shark man he didn't
know I was a human man I thought it was
a sheep no no he's always a human sold
the opportunity to eat them and that's
what he did yeah I don't know why we're
gonna make you just watch that video
yeah yeah horrifying
shark's doing shark [__] man they
shouldn't have killed him
it's so stupid when they kill the animal
oh that they said she should never mind
so it's just like oh man I think they
did kill him they said they did they
caught a tiger shark but how do you know
it's the one yeah it's almost impossible
man let's say cut his stomach well no
they they when the guy was getting
attacked the boat went out there to help
him and they they had a hook and grabbed
them pretty sure it was that time to
charge but typically I'm sure I'm
telling the video they didn't do that
though a boat comes out I know of guys
but they didn't you don't think they no
I know that's not what they did oh
really I thought they did no no
but typically when sharks have a feeding
thing I'm almost positive they did I
like your I like your attitude no I
think they did I like your energy I like
that you're saying that you don't think
they caught the real you sure didn't you
think there's a lot of tiger sharks in
the area that that boat didn't do it the
Indian the in the Egyptian police they
got a vessel like a way like long time
after they're just looking for a tiger
shark's like I didn't do [__] and they
just beat the [__] out of them yeah yeah
oh it's never makes sense but I
appreciate that you
it's fun I've they hooked it there did
you have fun did you have fun when I
went back home that's the first thing
one of my buddies said to me yeah they
came out and they said but George did
you have to have fun yeah all things won
that's all right did you have fun though
yeah I'm in Covina Covina this Thursday
Friday Saturday new little joint Little
Theater out there in Covina Laugh
Factory bought this have you heard of
this no yeah it's a new Laugh Factory
yeah where is that it's not too far uh
45 minutes no traffic we'll see with
traffic Covina traffic is about six
hours but that's cool traffic could be
nine hours but that's this Thursday
Friday Saturday come on out folks what
do you got B I got Denver this weekend
Mama I'm Coming Home
Thursday Friday Saturday Comedy Zone
next weekend Greenville South Carolina
uh Springfield Missouri Blue Room uh
July 20th July 21 22. I'll see you there
everybody but this weekend Denver let's
go
let's go all right kids love you big boy
merch drops this week get you some these
uh authentic jerseys are dropping we
have this one in the Pinstripes we have
the gray we got hats hoodies bigboy.com
get you some Covina Covina
[Music]
that's this week get you some all right
love you guys